pierre martinet un ancien agent du
service action de la dgse et fondateur
de wind corp security défense pierre
martinet bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors on le
disait plus de 120 pays
espionner est-ce que cela vous surprend
est ce que c'est le coup du siècle comme
se félicite la cia ou plutôt un scandale
d'état
oui bonsoir non c'est certainement le
coup du siècle mais c'est ça me surprend
absolument pas puisque c'est c'est
monnaie courante que des sociétés fait
que des services de renseignements de
divers pays utilisent des sociétés
écrans dans plusieurs parties du monde
pour avoir des des leviers pour soutirer
du renseignement parce que c'est le but
d'un service de renseignements c'est
avoir le plus de renseignements
possibles pour avoir toujours un coup
d'avancé sur l'échiquier l'échiquier
géopolitique ou économiques bien
évidemment après les âmes sensibles vont
crier au scandale d'état mais non ça ne
se prend pas et je pense que c'est un
seul coup du siècle pour avoir depuis la
faim depuis l'après seconde guerre
mondiale avoir fait l'acquisition de
sociétés de cryptage et avoir vendre
vendre du cryptage à des pays en ayant
les clients les coques c'est quand même
c'est quand même très forts de leurs
parts
alors il est effectivement cette
présence chez qui on sait là c'est
pareil pour la place publique croissante
en théorie cela n'aurait jamais dû
sortir alors justement comment est-ce
que cela sfax et pu sortir aujourd'hui
comment est-ce que vous expliquer
mais quelle formation et détenus par
deux personnes c'est difficile de la
garder secrète
certainement il ya eu des fuites ou
quelqu'un a parlé par par vengeance ou
par besoin de comment
je me flatte et son écho à la presse
donc voilà sortis normalement sans
jamais dû sortir
il ya aussi la durée et qui surprend
pendant près d'un demi-siècle 1 c'est
cet espionnage qu'est ce que ça vous
évoque la durée j'ai ça veut dire qu'ils
sont particulièrement particulièrement
compétent la durée le nombre de pays qui
ont été espionnées mai puis les autres
philosophiquement c'est c'est absolument
normal enfin je veux dire depuis que les
services de renseignements ici ceux qui
passent leur temps à espionner sont les
leurs avis leurs amis et encore plus
leurs amis ça fait partie un peu de lui
je veux dire du jeu de du monde du
renseignement
depuis que depuis qu'il existe c'est
d'avoir l'information avant l'heure pour
avoir un coup d'avancé il faut prendre
des décisions c'est ce qui fait la
grandeur d'un pays aujourd'hui ce qui
fait la force d'un pays en matière de
géopolitique qui en matière d'économie
c'est d'avoir l'information à vendre
pour pouvoir prendre la décision qui va
pouvoir faire avancer son pays sur plan
de la géopolitique ou sur l'échiquier
économique du monde
en tout cas sur ce coup là des
informations qui n'ont pas eu la france
pourquoi selon vous paris est il exclu
de cette opération
alors je pense que le cloisonnement
vient aussi de là la proximité avec avec
avec l'allemagne et après après la après
le comment dirais-je après la seconde
guerre mondiale la proximité avec la
mali avec le rideau de fer qui était qui
étaient là bas et c'était un plein de
guerre froide et ils avaient besoin
effectivement cette période d'avoir de
l'information que je pense que la france
est très ambigu avec les américains est
très ambigu sur beaucoup de sujets
notamment aujourd'hui et c'est peut-être
pour ça que les américains ça c'est mon
avis personnel c'est peut-être pour ça
que les américaines n'ont pas voulu
partager ça avec la france dans de
confiance peut-être alors quelles sont
les conséquences à votre avis cette
collecte de grande envergure est ce que
cela a plu
angers influencer des décisions
américaines par exemple absolument
puisque ce que je vous disais en
préambule c'est que avoir l'information
permet de prendre des décisions que qui
vont qui vont changer le cours de tel ou
tel contrat ou où je passe je pense
surtout aux pays du golfe avec avec en
ligne de mire le pétrole donc
effectivement ça a dû changer la donne
dans certains dossiers mais ça fait
partie du jeu c'est un service de
renseignement et effet pour avoir
l'information avant l'autre justement
quelle suite peut-être donner à ces
révélations notamment par les pays
concernés un plus de 120 pays
on le disait de leur côté qu'est ce qui
va se passer
une enquête il va il va y avoir un peu
des gesticulations médiatiques et puis
après ça va passer aux oubliettes
souvenez-vous il ya quelques années on
avait peine à crier au scandale quand on
se l'est rendu compte quand on a appris
que la msa et espionner toute la planète
depuis 1975 à la msa a été créé pour ça
donc ça fait beaucoup de bruit dans les
médias français notamment parce que les
médias français s'insurgent tout de
suite et c'est passé on est passé un
sujet au sujet suivant quelques quelques
jours quelques semaines après non il n'y
a pas de selon moi il y aura pas de
conséquence sur a peut être quelques
rappels le plat que quelques réunions
autour de l'ambassadeur mais ça ne niera
pas bien loin et la cia continuera à
espionner la nsa continuera espionner la
cia je pense que depuis depuis le temps
a réussi à voir des du cryptage de haut
niveau comme l'avait cette société et
ils ont où ils ont ils ont aussi
certainement délocaliser ou sous
traitées parce que c'est aussi la cia
sous traite beaucoup dans beaucoup de
domaines donc je pense que c'est de se
penser dans l'air du temps ça ça ne
changera pas grand chose à la
géopolitique et la géo stratégie du
reste de la place pour terminer en un
mot est ce qu'on pourrait s'attendre à
d'autres révélations de ce type dans les
mois à venir
je pense assez régulier qu'on on
absolument de révélations régulièrement
par parra part pour la presse parce
qu'il ya toujours des fuites
malheureusement et
ça permet aussi de se ré articulé de se
réorganiser et de trouver d'autres
d'autres manières d'autres façons
d'autres techniques pour continuer à
espionner puisque les services de
renseignement sont faits pour eux
merci beaucoup pierre martinet pour
votre soirée analyse je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien agent du service action
de la dgse et fondateur de wim core
security défense